It turns out that login is a special case of the general bind operation that I
described to you, and it is a special
case in the following sense. Password that the
user has for logging into the system at any point of time is used as the
handshake key to start with. And username is
used as a client ID. So, to initiate the
login session, the login process, the username given to the user
as the client ID, and the password as the HKC. But
other than that, it follows the same sequence of validating itself
to the server, and, similarly, validating the server to the client.
And at the end of that validation of both the client and the server, what the
server gives back to the login process, as I mentioned earlier, are a
pair of tokens. The secret token, and the clear token. And these two tokens
have to be sent securely on the wire, which is insecure. So
what the server will do is encrypt these two using
password as the handshake key. And therefore,
the login process can use the password to
decrypt the message that comes back from the
login server, and get these two tokens, secret
token and clear token. And these two tokens are kept by Venus for the rest of
this login session. And as we know, once
we've gotten these two tokens because clear token
is a data structure that contains the handshake key needed by Venus
for establishing RPC session, the rest of the life is made for us.